bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cette semaine à fort enjeu
diplomatique s'est ouverte lundi avec
une rencontre entre les vice ministres
des affaires étrangères russe et
américain en réunion donc ce mercredi à
l'otan avec les etats-unis la russie et
les européens avant une autre rencontre
ce sera à vienne demain rencontre de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe jusque là rien de
concret pas d'accord est ce que vous
diriez que le dialogue est déjà une
avancée en soi ah oui
le dialogue est une avancée en soi cela
fait plusieurs années que le dialogue
n'existait plus le dialogue était
tellement mauvais que le le cadre normal
des pourparlers entre la russie et
l'otan c'est-à-dire le conseil russie
otan
ne s'était plus réunie que les missions
de chaque partie dans la capitale de
l'autre c'est à dire les russes à
bruxelles et l'alliance à moscou avait
été retiré et là on parle de
réamorcer non seulement le dialogue mais
de réinstaller ces missions c'est à dire
que on assiste à ce que l'on peut
appeler un nouveau départ évidemment
tout ne va pas être réglé tous les
problèmes ne vont pas être réglée en
l'espace de quelques jours c'est un long
processus
qui ceux qui s'engagent
mais ce qui est très positif c'est que
alors que jusqu'à présent c'était les
russes qui étaient demandeurs de ce
dialogue de négociation de poser les
problèmes sur la table d'essayer de
trouver des solutions
maintenant ce sont les occidentaux qui
insiste sur la poursuite du dialogue ils
voulaient établir aujourd'hui un
calendrier de négociations pour l'avenir
et ce sont les russes qui ont dit très
intéressant votre proposition mais il
faut qu'on y réfléchisse c'est à dire
que quelque part lange de ces
négociations devient plus intéressant
pour les occidentaux que pour les russes
les deux ont intérêt à continuer le
dialogue mais ce qui est significatif
c'est que aujourd'hui contrairement au
passé les alliés occidentaux
ne ferme pas qu'on la porte des
négociations et au contraire les
encourage et dialogues aujourd'hui aussi
avec les européens les européens qui
redoutent d'être marginalisés dans un
face à face à amiens et cannes aux
russes quel point est ce qu'il pèse
réellement dans les négociations les
européens
les européens en tant que l'union
européenne ne pèse rien parce que ils
ont une position commune qui est très
minimaliste
en réalité
l'europe ne vaut que par ses poids
lourds qui sont la france l'allemagne
avant il y avait également le royaume
uni me n'est plus dans l'europe il y a
l'italie l'espagne qui compte mais
d'une manière globale l'europe ne peut
participer à ces négociations que d'une
manière marginale et par l'intermédiaire
de l'otan parce que la plupart des
membres de l'union européenne sont
également membres de l'otan ou par lots
et c'est eux c'est à dire l'organisation
la sécurité de la coopération en europe
dont la réunion aura lieu demain où tous
les pays européens y compris les états
unis et le canada qui ne sont pas
européens mais qui participe aux
négociations ainsi que la russie sont
englobés dans cette danse est ensemble
dans cette organisation
et il y à 50 ans ont commencé un cycle
de négociations à helsinki qui a abouti
à asseoir la détente entre l'union
soviétique et les pays occidentaux sur
des bases rennes et c'est les
négociations c'était la conférence pour
la sécurité et la coopération en europe
qui a donné par la suite naissance à
l'organisation
en question et il est très possible que
on assiste aujourd'hui à un retour
de ces négociations de l'époque d'il ya
50 ans qui ont réglé pas mal de
problèmes et qui ont permis
effectivement une évolution pacifique
sur le continent européen
il est possible que ce soit dans le
cadre de l'eau et c'est eux que les
choses sérieuses puisse commencer les
véritables négociations puissent
s'engager avec la participation de tous
les états européens alors moi ce qu'on
va mettre sur la table des propositions
interdire tout nouvel élargissement de
l'otan à l'ukraine ainsi qu'à tout autre
pays empêcher aussi les activités
militaires proches de la frontière russe
dont les pays de l'ancien espace
soviétique
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre des
différentes parties
bon les propositions russes
se base sur un principe le récit prend
de sécurité qui est dans l'est dans les
traités dans les textes c'est à dire que
un pays ne peut pas assurer sa sécurité
aux dépens de ses voisins
ça c'est le principe de base
évidemment l'otan est très réticente et
même hostile à l'idée de ne plus élargie
de ne pas englober éventuellement la
géorgie éventuellement l'ukraine mais il
y a une différence entre les
déclarations de principe et d'intention
et les réalités est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'otan est en mesure
de
donner à l'ukraine et à la géorgie une
place au sein de l'alliance
techniquement c'est relativement
difficile parce qu'en plus la situation
dans ces deux pays
n'est pas conforme à ce que l'otan
demande à ses membres donc là il y a une
possibilité pour que progressivement
bien que le principe de on veut élargir
et on élargira soit prononcée proclamer
haut et fort en réalité sur la table des
négociations
on pourra certainement trouver des
des accommodements qui permettront à
l'otan de sauver la face disons et à la
russie de parvenir à éviter s'est
élargie cement qui avait d'ailleurs
l'arrêt de l'élargissement avait été
promis à gorbatchev au moment de
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique et
cela n'avait pas été tenues et lorsque
j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler avec
gorbatchev sur ses mémoires et
regrettait fermement de ne pas avoir
obtenu un document écrit il pensait que
la parole de ses interlocuteurs en
l'occurrence le président bush père et
james baker son
secrétaire d'état suffisait ormond ce
n'était pas suffisant merci beaucoup
pour votre éclairage pierre laurent je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de la russie